if you're looking at somebody that  you're sizing up or if you're looking at  somebody to go into business with or if  you're looking at  a big investments you got to make what  is the decision-making process there do  you call is there first you do your own  research you take this much time you  call an advisor is there is there a  system yeah it's pretty pretty simple  for me it's it's do you understand the  business  is it a business that you can help in  some form or fashion  what are the barriers to entry to that  business  and then the entrepreneurs themselves  the company itself  right do they have a culture that you  believe is sustainable  are these leaders people that you  believe in  are they people that are obsessives  and in turn have they created a culture  of obsessiveness so i tend to look at  those four factors and that's it that's  that's big right there by the way i  don't know if you guys caught that right  that's pretty massive right there